hello I'm Matt Welch with Nick Gillespie
on ask a libertarian 2012 day we're here
to celebrate the paperback publication
of the Declaration of Independence our
next question comes via email Dave
Williams when I purchased my home at the
crest of the housing crash our town was
paying first-time homebuyers $3,000
toward closing costs no questions asked
I just walked into town hall and got
free money without asking them where it
came from I have since been wondering if
this is something that a libertarian
should avoid on principle should I repay
the town on principle ask a libertarian
ethicists nickel ya boy you know first
off whatever you want to do on principle
do it and speak loudly and clearly
that's great but one of the embedded in
that question is the idea that if you
benefit from a system you're not allowed
to criticize it and the kind of reductio
ad absurdum charge of this is that I
once heard somebody jokingly say you
know and Frank shouldn't shouldn't have
complained against Nazi Germany because
she got all those free train rides you
know and you know to bring it back to
something like this do it you know but
then talk about it and talk about why
it's wrong and you know there's no
reason to be cynical about this I know a
couple of people who have retired
they've refused to file for Medicare
which technically you have to accept
there's no way out of it and they're
hoping altima - you know crawl it cause
a Supreme Court case over being forced
into Medicare which is kind of an
interesting thing but the point is is
that we need to be talking about these
programs and where the money comes from
and how stupid it is so take the money
but don't run take the money and talk
more about why that giving you that
money was stupid in the first place
it's pretty impossible to live your life
without benefiting either in quotation
marks or without from the government and
I think it's a tall order to ask of
every single person who believes in a
limited government that they don't take
advantage of this stuff that said you
know whenever you find yourself taking
advantage the mortgage interest
deduction ask yourself is this a better
way to advance housing policy or policy
in general we talk a lot about reason
the various ways that middle-class
entitlements or
upper-middle-class entitlements whether
it's in in the mortgage interest
deduction or in student loan
artificially submerging interest rate
payments in student loans whether this
is just and whether it makes sense in
the context of a country that is out of
money and as Nick said that's a good
thing to to talk to other people about
and start spreading awareness on that's
ask a libertarian 2012 we're celebrating
the paperback publication of the
Declaration of Independence and we'll be
back shortly
you